hey guys this clip is brought to you by
Adam and Eve which offers sex toys for
him for her and for couples and it beats
a Pringles can you did not want d why I
DIY it'll sex products anal beads yes
pop only wants the best slighty types so
Adam and Eve Adam Eve if you're curious
you can go to Adam and Eve calm and use
the code tiger for 50% off one item plus
free shipping in the US and Canada some
exclusions apply that's Adam and Eve
calm and use the code tiger so last
night you know my brother you know he
expressed the kind of love for me that
I've never felt before in my life so
last night my brother and I you know we
we logged on to war zone and we did
duo's and you know we we got to the the
final circle and I killed four guys in a
row you know and my brother said oh I've
never been so proud of you of my life
Wow he was crying because I love you so
much
all right you're doing it man you're
doing it right and now I'm just I'm in
I'm in it you don't like that you know I
don't like a tree you know like you know
concentrate because you know you know
you're the finals you know the final
final star it's small right the smokes
coming in right my bass my gas massive
breaks right breaks right and then like
you know I mean I have three bullets
right and a bazooka one missile and I'm
going around and I you know wait I have
a question when you are in your final
circle let's say your brother is telling
you all of that like is he when you're
in the gulag
can you still see what your teammates
are doing yes so you can see what your
teammates are my brothers dead what it
does is York
green switches on to my point of view
okay right so my brother's not playing
anymore so now he is watching me play
Specter he's seeing what I'm seeing
right emotional it's emotional yeah so
he's watching every move what all the
things a lot of times it's like what are
you doing you mean
don't hide underneath that dumpster or
whatever I might be I'm sorry Remi but
this time it was like in tears I've
never seen him like this what are you
Rambo you kept say Grabow and I go boom
and uh obviously we got third place very
good for duo's but you know you've
played with me before on that game we've
all on we won yesterday we want a couple
days ago we won yeah and I get what 1
kill 2 kills maybe 1 or 2 kills right
but take do 6 right and get to that
final circle was a big achievement
because for the first 50 games I played
and each game takes about what 30
minutes sometimes sometimes yeah 45
minutes yeah all right I'll get one kill
or but my kill death ratio is zero
because I've died twice as more than
I've killed but in the last week or two
I'm now beginning to already call it off
set that ratio because I'm now figuring
it out but idea it was a really good
brotherly bonding experience last night
and it's the only time I get to hang out
with my brother you know so it is um and
he makes he makes me laugh does he not
make you laugh he's very funny he's very
cowardly he's very in the gutter
Bob just at the basement you support it
I know I support it so much what my
brother likes to do is he likes to go
okay I um see this house here let's just
hang out in the basement all game and
you're like yeah but we want to go out
and kill people know they'll come to us
so we'll sit there for 30 minutes
sometimes we'll spray paint cuz you can
spray paint in the game we'll spray
paint like what do you spray painting
you can spray paint like little pictures
and
different things I also had another
question about the game when you're
ready and then so my brother okay so um
guys
we'll just sit here hey we just sit
there and we'll spray paint each other
for like 20 solid minutes nothing going
on no shooting right and that's a
bonding experience yeah but then you'll
go but are your footsteps and then we'll
get on our bellies and get ready
you know me but that's the way my
brother likes to play what I begin
beginning to do is go on all right let's
go get after them I haven't play more
aggressive it's very much more
aggressive not very aggressive am I not
you but isn't the first to the fight the
bloodiest first one to the fight is the
bloody can anymore yeah that's actually
sounds legit what you just said right
but before right so you have this map
what we what I would do is okay guys um
let's go to the very edge of the map
where no one's gonna be all right but
now I'm going or let's land where
everyone else is landing right and
Gilbert I have to say you're very good
at the game you too sir I'm wise with
you you too sir
thank you now my question is I know that
you've spent some money on your outfits
$800 baby oh no real bleep that part out
you've spent $8 $1,000 baby
okay so would you say that a change and
how many outfits is up by it's not
outfits what your okay so what what you
buy is a you buy looks so there's no I
don't know 16 characters but each
character has a different clothing
apparatus okay so my question was is it
a morale boost and when you put on a new
look do you feel like you play better no
but I a through the character say my
brother just doesn't have any really
doesn't care about his look so he just
think the game just generates a certain
look for him so one game he's just like
a standard white soldier yeah but but
for me my the girl I play you know - all
those Nike yoga
pants you know she does right yeah he
does she does she has a hat she's got
you know I wanted to look good you know
I have another guy that looks like Sasha
Baron Cohen you know mean oh yeah yeah
then bring his muscle yeah he's got like
you know me a red beautiful turban and
scarves I like the scarves the boys I'm
her Jack it I have the black leather
jacket very cutoff is it idea of like
cutoff flannel no he's got a cutout
flannel is more Punk yeah he looks real
nice and if I'm gonna die I want to die
looking good yeah I think also like my
brother in terms of fashion mmm like
I'll go to uh sometimes we'll go to a
nice store a close like a shoe store get
something nice a little I got a little
extra money you want a chew you cos no
Bob I like the shoes that I have which
is he always loves Brown skater shoes
and they just look standard Brown you
know I couldn't I couldn't think of a
pair of brothers more dissimilar than
you and Steve he